[Music]
i think the greatest value of learning
how to i think everybody in this country
should learn how to program a computer
should learn a computer language because
it teaches you how to think it's like
going to law school i don't think
anybody should be a lawyer
but i think going to law school would
actually be useful because it teaches
you how to think in a certain way
in the same way that computer
programming teaches you in a slightly
different way how to think
and so i view computer science
as a liberal art it should be something
that everybody learn you know takes it
takes a year in their life one of the
courses they take is
you know learning how to program
programming is where you're describing
to the machine how to do
something and so telling it how to play
tic-tac-toe telling it how to play
the game board game monopoly telling it
how to convert numbers from one base to
another
and the idea of
okay there's these simple instructions
but if you put them together
then you can synthesize something quite
complex
it's a fascinating kind of mathematical
thing how can you make it fast how can
you make it small
you know the fact of understanding how
the computer works gives you a real
sense of what it can do and what it
can't do there's a lot of great jobs out
there
you know and and so we we don't have
programming enough
on the curriculum but i certainly
wouldn't put it at you know like math or
or literacy um
but you know it it there's a lot of
innovative stuff
that make it more interesting it's not
just for nerds like it was when when i
did it
programming is one of the only things in
the world that that you can do where
you can sit down and just make something
completely new from scratch you know
whatever whatever you want
i took one computer class in college and
i cheated at it you know
and and and
but when i started really getting into
it i could spend 20 hours teaching
myself the program and writing then
writing programs and i
was like i had no idea i love this stuff
right
and and i would just sit there and days
would go by and
and and i loved it right and then as i
got more into those businesses it was
like
this is great i'm having a blast doing
this but i didn't know
that's what i would love to do until i
tried a lot of different things
for a few it might lead to a lucrative
career as so-called coders
but for everybody it'll teach them how
to think
how to imagine how to create it'll
provide a better understanding
of the world and an indispensable
foundation for life
a lot of people think about programming
as the language that
tells peter what to do but in fact you
know if you look at the office behind us
programming when it's really good the
language itself
programming language is actually
communication between team members right
it's the difference between being able
to maintain something
and enable it to live and to sustain
versus versus not so if it's a great
language and everyone knows it
then it brings the team together and
they can really do amazing things very
quickly